hi everyone is this on people here
oh great so yeah excited to be talking
about some of the work that we're doing
at stitch fix on both the how and the
why of using a human intent to improve
our recommendation systems so stitch fix
is a online personal styling service so
how it works is you fill out a big like
style profile to tell us your price
preferences aesthetic that everything
about what you like to wear and how you
like to wear it then we use all of that
information to recommend what a human
stylist should put in the box to send to
you and so how it works I mean users
perspective is that you receive this box
of clothes you keep what you love you
send the rest back and we are a personal
styling service for everybody so right
now we serve women's men's and now kids
as of a year ago and we have a big range
of sizes to really inclusive from plus
to petite and we've been in the US for
about eight years but just on to the UK
a couple months ago which is part of why
I'm excited to be here so how we do
personalization at scale it's a really
hard problem and a big part of how we
get it done it is by combining expert
human judgment with the data science and
machine learning recommendations so
internally almost every team across the
company consumes recommendations from
the data science team as part of doing
their daily job and in order to get this
done we have more than 100 people on the
algorithms team in our San Francisco
headquarters
so a lot of people are working on some
flavor recommendations of there's also
people working on experimentation and
like warehouse and logistics I'm a huge
number of different problems so it's a
really fun place to work and my talk
about recommenders during this talk I'm
going to use a pretty broad definition
of what a recommender means so it's just
gonna be anything that where algorithmic
recommending or results are used to
guide a human making a decision it has
an effect in the real world that people
actually care about
so we're going to go through a couple
different examples of recommendation
systems that were working on one it is
for the stylists and their job is to
decide what to put in the box to send to
an individual client and the second
example I'm going to talk about today is
for the buyers so there's the separate
team of people had such beds whose job
it is to decide what we're gonna stock
in the warehouses I mean that some teams
I actually worked with and that's the
example that we're gonna go through the
second so get started by building some
fake styling recommend areas so to set
the stage a little bit let's think about
how our recommendations for March work
in the real world so we're gonna do a
little bit of role play I'm gonna play
myself and have a lovely volunteer from
the audience he's gonna play my friend
so suppose I want to be asked my friend
for recommendations about something I
was in the market for a new backpack
recently so what backpack should I get
well I love my old messenger backpack
but I'm looking for a regular backpack
this time I like that it's waterproof
it has good pockets it fits my laptop
I'm in flaccid for a really long time so
I want something sturdy and it looks
pretty cool too well the one that I have
fits okay but I want something that fits
even better if it's pretty important to
me and it would be fun to try a new
brand that I haven't had before
so what just happened here
um I provided my friend with some of my
general preferences these were things
that were true about my preferences in
the past that are also true in the
present and in the future I also
provided some specific preferences that
hadn't been true in the past so things
bad and if my friend didn't know this
for some reason they wouldn't have been
able to guess it necessarily I also
provided some explicit pieces of
information things that were fairly
objective that if you were building some
kind of tagging system these probably
come up in your tags but I also provided
some more implicit information that you
would have to have outside knowledge
about me or about the backpack industry
or something else in our day to infer
what the information I was providing
actually men within your system so how
do you some standard recommender systems
incorporate these different kinds of
information so in collaborative
filtering um the standard across the
industry Amazon huge number of other
places use different flavors of this
this is the people who bought this also
bought kind of recommender system so at
statistics this would look like matrix
where you have clients along the rows
pieces of merch along the columns and
one if they bothered before a zero if
they hadn't and you run this through
your favorite matrix factorization let
me get recommendations this is entirely
based on general information about their
past behavior and it's also entirely
based on implicit information so when
someone has bought an item in the past
they didn't buy that item with the
intense of training your algorithm
better they bought it because they
wanted to have it and so all of this
implicit information may or may not be
relevant to the specific situation that
you're working on and this causes a lot
of problems when people's preferences
are changing over time and so there's
this fun like hacker news thread where
people were complaining about all the
different situations in which Amazon is
giving like they search for a vacuum
once and Amazon never stops showing them
vacuums like they don't want that
anymore
so we care about doing better than this
so say we want to start incorporating
some explicit information for instance
like profile questions so content-based
recommenders is one way to do this so at
such fix this might look like this user
has said they like puppy clothes they
like goth clothes they like cream and
then you could get those same labels for
all of our items of March and compute
some distance metric between the user
and items and use that to rank the
recommendations this is nice because
when the user fills out their profile
they're doing it with the intent of
getting recommendations that match the
profile questions that they're filling
out so it seems like it took people
irrelevant
but this can cause problems to this user
likes preppy clothes and goth clothes
they want this at the same time they
need given time how do we know which one
they want
and so preferences can often be
incompatible and if you think about this
from that OkCupid perspective this is
like okay keep its rectum also you can
think about your own dating preferences
and you probably have preferences for
different kinds of partners that might
be incompatible in the same person but
you still like those in different people
for different reasons so now what if we
say okay we can do better than this look
at literature see but like a little more
anisha algorithms are out there and
there's field of context to where
recommendations and what that generally
means is getting location there were
time information things that you can
defer from the user is like yeah clock
or IP address or things like that I'm
throwing those columns into your
collaborative filtering algorithm and
getting recommendations based on that so
this is like people in your situation
also bought these items this is getting
a bit better but it still has the
fundamental problem that people like you
were kind of boring any recommendation
that is going to be for users like you
well by definition that before a person
who is a little bit more average than
you are in terms of your program says
and stitch mixes in the business of
enabling self-expression and so we won't
settle for something
that is only recommending it's something
that's a little bit more average so what
do we do instead we just explicitly ask
for people's specific preferences so
when someone signs up to receive a box
of clothes they have an opportunity to
fill out a free text box so they might
say something like I love the distressed
jeans and the last fix but this time I'd
like something totally different
I wanted outfit to go to my cousin's
wedding and this is something we never
would have guessed looking at their past
purchases looking at their profiles
questions and we have to have pretty
invasive like social media permissions
in order to guess this we don't want to
go down that road I'm instead we just
like ask people what they want and then
we give them what they want and so you
can treat this as something like search
terms or NLP and the second example
we're going to be talking about it takes
the form of something where the
configuration parameters so this has
been a really great framework for thank
us to think about how to design
recommendation algorithms and you can
use the features that are coming out of
this in classical recommender or
situations or in other kinds of
algorithms you can also think of it
through the lens of explore exploit so
all the standard information from
collaborative filtering or tags helps
you exploit um you already know how to
do that but this specific information is
great for guided exploration it's a new
territory that you have next word of
that user yet um it's also fun from a
philosophical standpoint um people grow
and change over time and of course your
users are kind of want different things
in the future than they have in the past
and so it's a fundamentally optimistic
algorithmic framework and the practice
has just led to really good outcomes for
us so when the stylist has the more
standard classical recommendations
paired with the human readable and human
generated text they can make really good
decisions on behalf the client
so let's look at the second example now
so the buyers are the people who decide
what clothes were gonna be carrying and
that's the team that I work with so we
have a data science team that was
specifically tasked with working with
this internal team of my areas so let's
go through the example of building a
real rich recommendation system so how
the merge teams job worked in the past
was that they would get a list of all
the merch that was available from all
the vendors that we work with and since
they were lucky enough to work at a
place like such fix each of those items
comes with a automatically generated
performance metric so we think we know
how well it's gonna do in the future
they have this information and they go
through these lists and they pick the
items off the list that we want to be
carrying again this in a lot of ways is
similar to a standard ecommerce
experience and part of the value props
of stitch fix for the clients is that
they don't have to do that standard an
e-commerce had to be unpacking
themselves so we thought that we could
probably do better than this for our
internal wires also so how the original
tool that we built for them worked was
they would enter some kind of intent in
the form of just a filter say I want to
be looking at shirts that would get sent
to a back-end API which would pull in
the predictions for how well each item
of clothing is gonna do with different
client segments in the future I'm that
good filtered and sent back to the user
so pretty straightforward but over time
as we continue to develop this internal
tool the buyers kept asking for all
these like additional filters and
combinations of filters and knobs and
dials and bells and whistles and both
sides were getting pretty frustrated
with each other about trying to figure
out how to combine all of these features
and see you ex-mate that made sense and
how to rank how to be prioritizing
building them and it was just kind of a
mess and so we step back
and had some deep like user research
conversations with the internal team of
buyers like what problem are we actually
trying to solve here how are we trying
to build this assortment of marriage and
we ended up realizing something that we
probably should have realized from the
beginning which is that very don't care
about choosing items up a list they care
about running a business so in addition
to optimizing this performance metric
they care about choosing merch that is
they worse across all of the ways in
which our clients are they're worse
price points fit aesthetic everything
else I'm we're running a profitable
business and so they care about meeting
our financial targets merchandising is a
very seasonal and long lag time process
and so they care about getting
seasonally relevant merch and at the
right time and we care about having
supply matched demands and so getting
exactly the right amount of each item is
every time so we step back and thought
about all of these from a different
algorithmic framing we thought we're
trying to maximize this performance
metric subject to all of these
constraints let's use constrained
optimization inside of a standard
recommendation system so we formulated
this as a problem that where our
decision variable is the number of units
of any item of march to be socking and
we choose that in order to maximize the
overall predicted performance of the
whole collection of march subject to all
of the constraints that we talked about
on the previous slide and it's taking a
fair bit of work to formulate all of
these as equality or inequality
constraints but we've pretty much gotten
there now how many we solve it with PMO
which is an open source packet has
Python bindings it's been working pretty
well for us but the documentation is
kind of terrible so several teams at
such fix are using high mo for
optimizations and one of them
Jeff Schechter has written a blog post
on our blog multi-threaded that has a
much better tutorial than anything else
they found on the Internet
so if you hear yes I would start there
so - we architect the system in order to
use the constrained optimization framing
and we change the front ends it's so
that instead of yeah now the user who's
the buyer enters their strategic intent
for what they sort my different which is
gonna look like so things like margin
etcetera that user intent is translated
into constraints of the optimum the
optimizer can do in and the optimizer
combines those constraints with exactly
the same predictions that we were
working with earlier finds optimal
solution and returns back to the user
and so now they go from a strategic
intent all the way to a full set of
recommendations in one single step from
their perspective so this has been
working way better
it does have some technical challenges
though so one is around speed we've
introduced this real-time optimization
stop which is likely to be pretty slow
so it was important to make sure that
all of the other sets of pipeline were
fast so on the API side just standard
like caching and other optimizations
there it can help it became extra
important for us to be doing our model
training and prediction in offline and
batch ETLs so we were doing this before
but if we hadn't we would probably have
had to move to doing this in order to
enable the new real time step there also
a lot of challenges from the UX
perspective because this was a
completely fundamentally different way
of the buyer is doing a really important
part of their job so we had to at design
interfaces that encouraged the buyers to
encode their intent in a way that the
algorithm was gonna understand and
educate the buyer is about how the
algorithm is going to work so that they
could do that well and then when the
recommendations were shown back to
we had to include a lot of contacts so
that they can make good decisions based
on that those recommendations that were
several stops removed from the
underlying productions and maybe the
coolest part is that this new framing
enabled buyers to iterate through this
cycle many times so for instance they
could look at this assortment and say
like oh wait there's no black here we
need to carry something black and so
they could go back to the targets and
our new target and go through the cycle
again and get a completely different set
of recommendations out of the same set
of predictions so decoupling the
predictions from the recommendations
enables this whole different way of
working after we designed the system we
realized that it's actually parallel to
a lot of other systems that are out
there so Maps for instance so parallel
is that you'd start by entering at ura
int n in this case the start and the
destination that would get passed down
to the routing engine which would pull
in the predictions of travel times in
this case and pass it back to the user
in the form of recommended route to take
so cool things about this is that it
enables data science to separate the
prediction tasks from the recommendation
tasks so we were already doing that
protection but having that separate
recommendation task as a middle layer
here sets up a really nice clear
separation of concerns between the
people that are working on like batch
offline ETLs and the people who are
working on we all time online tasks and
so we've actually started to organize
some of our teams internally along these
divisions it does have technical
challenges though so if your data
science themes are not used to working
with raw user input you're gonna have to
learn how to do that and if you don't
have
task queues or job run our kind of
architecture setup that was pretty
important for us to get this working
it's totally worth it from the users
perspective though so the ability to ask
different questions and get different
answers out of a recommendation system
is totally game-changing and it makes it
much more similar to the conversation
that we had about the backpack where if
I had given different answers or if my
friend had asked me different questions
we'd buy the first as a very different
point for the recommendation but that
great power does come great
responsibility for the user though they
have to learn how to have a conversation
with an algorithm which is a pretty hard
thing for some users to do so everything
you can do from the UX perspective to
encourage that structure thinking really
helps so to wrap up um by collecting in
the moment specific preferences as well
as general preferences and ten different
algorithms and evil recommendations that
change over time as people's preferences
change over time and by allowing users
to explore many different possible
scenarios it enables users to yeah deal
with situations where they might have
two sets of incompatible preferences but
they want to know what the outcome might
be if they go down either path and by
stepping outside of the framework where
there's just one right answer and
allowing many possible answers it really
opens up the space in which users can
explore and play and puts the user back
in the driver's seat so instead of
algorithms limiting users options now
users are in control and can make
decisions on their own behalf without
the algorithm getting in the way
thanks very much so we have a few
minutes for questions to put your hand
up and I'll come around the microphone
thank you so much we did amazing
presentation about the how these signs
can really help certain different types
of decision we do you know one thing you
mentioned casually I think it's like
striking is what happens if someone
forgets to order black clothes do you
have anything around anomaly detection
to test the money makes me but it seems
like there's a big thing you're
forgetting which is not really in your
prediction not really in the intent but
difference between them
do you have a way for people to express
the fact no I will not order anything
back this season because this is an
intention this is a historic decision
how does that are you asking whether we
have or hey there's no black here did
you actually want to have some black or
you're asking whether we are tracking
neither at the moment but those are sort
of next to the features that we want to
be working on incredibly important to
making sure that the user doesn't have
so much control do they get themselves
into a corner where that really knows
that
yeah so one reason why he chose pan was
that it was already getting really good
traction with some other teams of
subjects so it was pretty well proven
and some of the other teams are using it
for integer solve our problems so it's
nice for problems with yeah a different
range like that CVX pi is only for
convex problems and we wanted the option
of not come back to the hairtail so it
sounds like you've got these kind of
predictors or the one step that you're
kind of trading separately I mean you've
got a separate optimization problem yeah
do you think there's any gonna benefit
of kind of doing end to end so that you
so I think there are times when that
could be a helpful way to think about it
one reason where we like to separate it
is that we have not just one prediction
going into this but the whole collection
of predictions there might be different
teams across the company that are
generating each of those and so that
separation of concerns is worth it for
us at this moment but yeah definitely
something we're going to keep an eye on
so how do you test the accuracy of those
systems where you have human interaction
and also selected options yep so in the
stylist example oh you can use the same
kind of evaluation metrics as for any
other recommendation system so did the
stylist put things in the box at the
client's decided to keep in the context
of this additional information so that
part's exactly the same in the context
of the buyer problem yeah it's just kind
of by definition like was the result
that was returned to the user something
that I'm at their initial constraints so
that's just the metric here is whether
the constraints were feasible in the
first place and so I that stuff it's a
UX problem of how do you encourage the
user to get customers yes we have a
variety of different ways that we track
that so one is on the questionnaire that
you fill out at the beginning at least
in some versions of it one of the
questions is literally how adventurous
are you
you can although yeah there's other
questions like how often do you want
different kinds of clothing like going
out clothes or professional clothes
eight different things like that um so
that's one big things just like yes
another it is there is a separate source
of data that I haven't talked about yet
that's called style shuffle which is
kind of like tinder for clothes and so
we got a lot of like
up thumbs down ratings and that's
another really powerful source of data
that we have for learning at both the
specificity and the breadth of people
style preferences I think you mentioned
it's a primarily again specifically for
the customer clothes recommendation or
is it even adds oriented could you tell
us just a bit more about this truck hood
maybe to put it in perspective it's not
like 1% of the company or is that yeah
so the the algorithms team overall is
what I said is more than 100 people now
and that includes people working on the
Mort recommender is like I am also
people working on the styling
recommendations also people working on
customer acquisition funnel as well as
demand forecasting and logistics and a
huge swath of other problems
thank you for so much for the talk I
wanted to ask you said search search oh
I forgot to add like a very special term
that we really need to good result it
might be a good match for the sources
they given but it's just a bad search
yeah so yeah I think a couple of these
questions are about suppose that we
actually buy the set of merch that was
recommended by any one of these
iterations through the recommender what
are the outcomes gonna be for the
business at the end of the day and was
that part of the question um so in that
case we would want to run experiments on
the different versions of this and try
to develop the counterfactual of what if
we had carried this of a set of March
what would the business outcomes be and
so yeah experimentation frameworks like
that are the ultimate way to test the
value of these algorithms
that's what they told my question is do
you believe that the other approaches
such as cotton-based or collaborative
filtering should generally be replaced
by more 10 driven approaches or
applications I think that incorporating
user intent matters most when the user
is conscious that they're making a
choice and has some intent in the first
place so for instance for something like
news recommendations or social media if
all the user wants to do is really just
like keep scrolling it then that's a
very different kind of metric to be
optimizing for but in this case where
are they making a decision and they care
about the result of that decision in the
then incorporating everything that they
have in their head and to make the
recommendations relevant for them at
that moment I think makes a difference
do you have any explicit mechanism in
the UI to allow the client to to express
some intent of so one thing we have
along those lines is after summon it
receives their box of clothes and is
deciding what to keep and what to send
back there is a feedback that we
collected that stage so someone might
say I loved the fit of this but the
style wasn't good and so I'm not going
to keep it or I loved everything about
it by the wasn't in my price range so
I'm not going to keep it and so we
collect all of that feedback to sort of
curiosity personally what proportion of
people actually send stuff back with
feedback is obviously a natural bias not
to send stuff back I'm just curious how
you yes so that check out feedback we
get from an extraordinarily high amount
of clients actually yeah so it's yeah a
really high quality data ok great any
other questions ok awesome I think we'll
end it there then thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]